roses with us in st. Louis hi rose
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show well
thank you sir first I want to let you
know before I ask the question our
family's completely debt-free since 2002
and we're working on building Oh what do
you want to call it we have some savings
in a 401 K a 40 K and I'm disabled my
husband's retired we're waiting for his
full security to kick in my question is
when we start investing a little bit
more I don't want to end up being the
very type of rich person that I despise
the most because I have family that was
like that and their nose would be so
high in the air that you could build an
eagle's nest or an eagle could build its
nest in it and I just want to make sure
that I don't want to be that kind of
person because I've seen those people
and I can't stand the sight of them yeah
I don't blame you that's a smart thing
to be concerned about most of the time
like 99% of the time wealth does not
make someone a jerk it exposes the fact
that they already were wealth is
generally wealth is generally a
magnifying glass it makes you more of
what you already were if you have a bit
of a temper you can become an absolute
raging bully if you are a compassionate
kind giving person you make generosity
the path of your life and we call you a
philanthropist these are the kinds of
that wealth makes you more of what you
already are also the good parts of your
relationship say with your husband or
your kids get even better and the bad
parts are strained even more and so if
you have for instance a relative that
tries to mind your business all the time
well way do you get a little money
they'll mind your business a lot you
know and so everything gets expanded you
know what I'm saying and so I think and
and I you know I I know a lot of wealthy
people we've
made it a practice to cause people to
become wealthy number one but number two
to get to know them in the process and a
lot of friends and the circles that I
run in and the vast majority of them are
wonderful people because honestly the
vast majority of people are wonderful
people but I know below that are jerks
that are poor and I know people that are
rich that are poor I know people that
are stuck up about being poor they got
their nose up in the air and are proud
of being poor don't you the funny thing
about all this is that I'm happy where I
am and people our family tends to think
we're the poor family but we're the ones
of our house paid for is not which is
how I'd like to keep it if I were you
just let them think what they want to
think who gives a rip your living this
thing for you and your husband your kids
we're not we're not we're not trying to
put on the dog we're not trying to show
off that's how that's not what we're
doing that's not who you are so I got to
tell you you're fun you're a little
sassy and you're when you get some money
when you get some money you're gonna be
more fun and a little sassier have fun
with it Rose open phones at Triple Eight
8 to 5 5 2 to 5 you know we talk about
that stuff a lot in the legacy journey
class and in the clan in the book I did
on wealth all the other books I've
written were about money and most of you
bought those books and that's where you
are you're working your way out of debt
you're learning how to do a budget and
that kind of stuff but wealth is has got
some philosophical and doctrinal things
from a person of faith perspective
that's trained you and make you stop and
think there are people out there
wandering around who are not
knowledgeable about the Bible as an
example and think that being wealthy is
evil or that money is evil and those are
people who are biblically illiterate but
they're out there and some of them carry
a Bible around they just hadn't opened
it much they think it's going to jump
through their arm by osmosis or
something but you know there's a lot of
judgmental people out there around this
subject and it's very interesting my
friend Greg Craig Groeschel who's a
pastor of one of America's most six
that's for churches today says why is it
well why is wealth the only blessing
that Christians apologize for mmm
makes a body think you don't apologize
if God blesses you with health or with a
great marriage or great kids you know
you had a part in all of those things
you took care of your body you worked on
your marriage you made your kids behave
but also having those things is a
blessing from God and we don't apologize
for that blessing but when we work hard
to get some money oh we're supposed to
feel bad about that we're supposed to
hang our head like we've done something
wrong according to some of you no not me
I celebrate success I celebrate people
who win I like it when you go do the
things it takes to win I like it when
our farmer plows his field gets the
weeds out puts the seed in the ground
and has a bumper crop baby high-five you
do reap what you sow you're gonna get
back from this life what you put into
this life you're going to get back from
that job what you put into this job
there once was a guy walking along a
path heading towards the next town he
came upon an old man and the old man
yeseo man he said how do you find the
people in that town over there and the
old man said how did you find him in the
last town he said oh they were awful he
said you'll find him the same five
minutes later he ran the old man ran
into another guy and he said how do you
find the people in that town over there
and he said how did you find them in the
last town he said there were wonderful
people and he said you'll find them the
same you get out of this life what you
put into it